Sacrifice is a part of any journey.
Taking on these great challenges
against great odds...
...that's what makes us human.
- "For All Mankind" is an
alternate history of the space race.
- When we come back in to Season 2,
it's almost 10 years later.
It's 1983.
Both sides expand on their moon bases,
and the competition between
the two superpowers
has also gotten much more intense.
- We're coming in
to an alternate history of the new 1980s.
The social change is more rapid,
the development
of technology goes much quicker.
- (alarm chirps)
- No more gas stations.
I got 60 miles on a single charge.
- We have electric cars,
we have cell phones.
Because the Russians
land on the Moon first,
NASA is not defunded,
and it pushes us further into technology
in a competitive way.
- This is Jamestown Actual.
Enjoy the show, everyone.
- In space,
Jamestown has expanded drastically.
There's up to 30 astronauts
on the Moon at any given time.
It's a really exciting
leap forward in Season 2.
- Let me state as plainly as I can.
The greatest threat
the United States faces
is posed by the Soviet Union.
- There's rising tensions
between the superpowers.
The Cold War, rather than cooling off,
it's the exact opposite.
- It becomes about
ownership of the Moon
by militarizing the Moon
to try and stake a claim.
- The President wants us
to confront the Soviets on the Moon.
- They're going to need weapons, right?
- We see the military presence
and how that affects
life on the Moon.
- We need to send a message
to the Soviets.
- But there's
gotta be another way.
- I recommend go to DEFCON 3.
- Season 2 is everything you loved
about Season 1
taken a step further.
- Bringing the Cold War conflict
to the Moon
is a big part of Season 2.
It will be quite a shock and surprise.
- Follow emergency power protocols,
-scram the nuclear reactors.
- Copy.
- It's just an exquisitely
executed show
about human beings
in extreme situations.
- Once we do this thing...
...there's no going back.
- PRESIDENT REAGAN: History has asked
much of the Americans of our time.
Much more we must
be prepared to give.